let's talk about the world's biggest
garbage dump
space houston we have a problem
[Applause]
unlike on earth when we stop using
something or it becomes broken we can
let it fall to the ground but in space
nothing falls there are hundreds of
millions of pieces of junk up there and
the problem has already caused
astronauts to scramble for safety a
tense moment on the international space
station the object
the worst case scenario has already had
the hollywood treatment
and all this has got scientists worried
we cannot wait longer it's time to act
so how did space become a junkyard how
do you pick up trash moving faster than
a speeding bullet
and why could something called the
kessler syndrome make space flight
impossible
space junk can be anything from old
satellites and spent rockets to stray
bolts and even tiny flecks of paint
now most of this stuff is floating
around in low earth orbit that's the
part of space closest to earth and the
part that's used the most there are
thousands of satellites up there and the
international space station too and
stuff there is moving fast objects can
zip around at more than 27 000
kilometers per hour so if a piece of
junk hits something it packs a punch
we're looking at
possible collisions between working
satellites and bits of junk at these
incredibly high speeds that can be
catastrophic
to the objects that collide satellites
are not built to withstand such energies
impacting them the problem's been
building since we started launching
things into space
[Music]
first pictures from a czech newsreel of
bleep the russian red moon from the
first satellite sputnik in 1957 until
today
there are now more than 7 500 orbiting
the earth a mix of operational
satellites and dead ones that have just
been left there and the numbers are only
going up
way up
[Music]
spacex alone plans to launch more than
40 000 satellites over the next few
years and other companies also have
several thousand in the pipeline
why so many well two main reasons the
first is modern life depends on
satellites like crazy for mobile phones
and gps navigation in 100 meters turn
right to military uses and weather
forecasting now the second reason there
are so many satellites is that it's
getting much easier to launch them
they're getting much smaller and a bunch
of private companies are getting
involved
some are even creating satellite
broadband mega constellations ranging
from several hundred satellites to a few
thousand
but the business of space infrastructure
is making a mess because every satellite
launch creates space junk the rockets
sending them up there have parts known
as stages which break off and when the
satellite is finally released the
protective cover nuts bolts and wires
are also left behind now some of this
junk loses altitude and burns up in the
earth's atmosphere
but not all of it the upper stage of the
rocket that delivers it will frequently
stay in orbit it might only stay there
for a few months or a few years but some
have been up there for decades there are
also other ways that space junk gets
created and there are two major
incidents you need to know about china
last thursday succeeded in shooting down
one of its own aging weather satellites
that was the first it was in 2007 when
china tested a missile to destroy
satellites the strike created 35 000
bits of space shrapnel the largest junk
creating incident in history
the other incident happened in 2009 when
a dead russian satellite collided with
an operational american one
both were destroyed and thousands more
pieces of space junk were created
those two events alone increased large
space debris by a massive 70 percent but
it's not just big pieces of junk that
are the problem if anything the bigger
pieces are easier to deal with because
they can be tracked and hopefully
avoided but the tiny ones tracking them
is much harder and they can still cause
serious damage a millimeter size object
can definitely damage a working
satellite but something one centimeters
in size can definitely uh render a
satellite that we care about
useless so think what that could mean
for google maps and all those other
satellite services we rely on and then
think about what it could mean for
spacecraft carrying people since 1999
the iss has had to change course almost
30 times to avoid a collision worst
cases
the station is hit by a smaller size
object 10 centimeters
punches a hole into the pressurized
you know compartment somewhere
that's going to be really
serious and then there's the kessler
syndrome in the 1970s nasa scientist
donald kessler suggested that space junk
could reach a kind of tipping point as
more junk builds up the more crashes
there will be and in turn even more junk
is created it could lead to a
never-ending cycle of destruction
and create an exponentially growing ring
of junk around our planet for you wall-e
fans out there it's a bit like this
in reality it would neither be that easy
nor that cute ultimately that ring of
junk could make many kinds of space
activity too dangerous basically we'd
all be stuck on earth so much for that
getaway weekend to the moon if we made a
lined one to 10 and the tesla syndrome
was 10
everybody would say we don't want to get
to that line we want to be somewhere
before we get to that point where it's
unusable so what's the answer well the
first recommendation is stop polluting
the
space debris community has come up with
a set of guidelines
to mitigate that proliferation of debris
to flatten the curve they say things
like when you plan a space mission you
ought to have a plan for its end of life
you're either going to
boost the old spacecraft up incredibly
high out of harm's way
or you have to have enough fuel left
for it to
lower its orbit and get dragged into the
earth's atmosphere people have also been
experimenting with ways to collect the
trash
like giant nets
fishing in orbit if you like
or there's pinning a tail on a satellite
to create enough drag so it slows down
and enters the atmosphere to burn up
or powerful magnets that could collect
the junk but the problem is who's going
to pay for the cleanup and who's going
to police it there isn't like one
authority who can say right you made
this junk you go and clean it up and
enforce that there's a lot of reliance
on
um people being good space citizens most
people are not compliant with the
guidelines because the guidelines are
not
in a space law
so so it's up to individual countries
to take these guidelines make these
interface law and then enforce these
things on their own
citizens but so far not a single country
in the world has actually done that and
time is running out if i look at the
current environment
it's it's not too late but it's five to
twelve it's it's really we we have to
act now because it will take time to
develop the technology needed these are
mistakes of the past
and we have to correct them
space is being colonized by us humans
and our technology faster than ever but
the garbage is piling up
someone's gotta take out the trash
in case you missed it check out our last
episode about what's going on in lebanon
and make sure to subscribe to al
jazeera's youtube channel so you don't
miss our next one see you next week
[Music]